all right everybody we are here in Miami
you see who I'm with
it's opening weekend and a surprise
dinner or people theater full of people
for hustlers tonight we're excited they
don't know we're here here we go
[Applause]
we thought this movie in like 29 days a
lot of overtime but it was worth it and
I hope you guys have the best time
tonight Jennifer Lopez crushing it in
all aspects of her life professionally
with hustlers and personally planning
her upcoming wedding to fiancé Alex
Rodriguez now Alex did give a hint to
Michael Kiki and Sarah the other day
about your wedding wedding clue he's
gonna be a long flight yeah I know he we
don't know yet so he's just say agents
and stuff yeah he's saying things but
you know we're talking about it but we
don't have any firm plans and we saw
nobody a lot of places but I don't know
yes you like even years I began narrow
it down yet well here at your son's a
little moon of course I love that not
only is JLo getting big buzz about
hustlers she's also in the running to
take on the biggest stage in the world
the Super Bowl a source told me this
week that the superstar entertainer is
at the top of the NFL's list what would
it mean to end the year on that stage I
mean it would be awesome yeah you know I
think every again it's like when your
little girl and you're dreaming you know
want to be an actress oh you want to be
a singer there's certain like things
that you hope to accomplish one day and
that's definitely one of them so it
would be will be amazing